hey legal eagles one of the questions I
get most from college students is what
is the best undergrad degree or major to
prepare you for law school well today
I'm gonna talk about the various pros
and cons of different degrees and by the
end of this video you will know what is
the right major for you so stick around
[Music]
the thing about law school is that it
takes a lot of different skills working
in conjunction with each other first and
foremost you have to be a great writer
second you have to be good at
researching you have to be good at
logical thinking you have to be able to
make good policy argument stemming from
philosophy in government you have to be
good at historical precedent you have to
be a good orator all of these things
need to work in conjunction if you're
going to get the most out of law school
and you have to use all of these skills
together in order to be a successful law
student to get good grades
I'm as a result there is no one major
that prepares you for law school law
school is unlike anything else in
undergrad in high school there is just
simply nothing like it and there is no
one major that really prepares you for
what law school is like final exams in
law school are based on what's called an
issue spotter hypothetical where you're
required to think like a lawyer
no undergrad major prepares you for
thinking like a lawyer
in fact Law School doesn't even prepare
you for thinking like a lawyer either
that's why we created a master class to
actually teach students how to think
like a lawyer and classes in law school
are taught using the Socratic method
which is also completely different from
almost any seminar or lecture that
you've had in college or in high school
professors pepper their students with
questions to reveal the right answer
much in the same way that it's said that
Socrates peppered his disciples Plato
and Aristotle with questions to let them
find the right answer but this
methodology it's totally unlike anything
that you'll see in college especially
where you have large classes of
hundreds of people or more where there
just simply isn't the ability to go back
and forth between any particular student
and the subject matter in law school is
also totally different from any
undergrad subject no one will teach you
the log you need before you get to law
school sure you might take a business
law class or an accounting law class but
that is such a small tiny percentage of
what you're going to cover in law school
that there's no way for any particular
major to really lay the foundation of
what you will need to know in law school
so the question is this if no major
really prepares you for law school and
no major can prepare you for law school
what major should you sign up for in
college to best prepare you for law
school well the answer that I always
give is this you should sign up for the
major that you are most interested in
get a degree in a subject that you find
fascinating law schools don't care about
your major when you apply to law school
no law school is gonna look at which
particular major you had but they do
care about what grades you got in
college or undergrad so if you major in
something that you're really interested
in you are much more likely to put more
effort into it and to do well in college
and that will translate into better
grades not to mention you will have
spent four to five years studying
something that you really enjoy because
you're never going to get that time back
odds are you're probably going to enjoy
law school less than your time in
college so you might as well enjoy the
most out of your college experience so
sign up for a major get a degree in
something that you find fascinating and
you're willing to study for four years
then when you show up for your first day
of law school you'll be in basically the
same boat as everybody else you'll be
starting from zero because no one's
major or degree actually prepared them
for law school so it's okay that you're
starting from the same point as
everybody else
so what is the best major for you well
that
it depends on your personal preferences
what do you enjoy studying what are you
fascinated by what can you see yourself
studying for four to five years and what
can you reasonably do to get good grades
in that particular major so
unfortunately I can't give you one
particular answer that works for
everybody there is no one major that
works for all law schools and even
pre-law majors don't really prepare you
for law school for those of you who are
unsatisfied with in it depends answer
well I'm sorry to say that you're gonna
have to get used to it because if you're
going to become a lawyer you're going to
hear it depends a lot if you ask an a
lawyer anything nine times out of ten
you'll get the answer that it depends so
let me know what major did you sign up
for what are you going to study in
college and what have you been studying
do you feel like it was a good use of
your time for four years if you want
even more strategies and tactics before
you get to law school download our free
ultimate pre-law checklist
it's our free gift to you the link to
that is down below and it will give you
a head start before you get to law
school also please click on the like and
subscribe buttons the more people that
subscribe to this channel the more
videos we'll make on how to crush law
school and until next time at legal
eagle think like a lawyer and ace the
exam so the thing about law school is
that it takes a hold there
in a Socratic method Aristotle Plato
well the answer that I always give
people I'm trying